um i i saw your name listed or linked
with uh interview with the vampire
what's going on with that
um that's funny amc is uh has acquired
the rights to all of anne rice's uh
novels and her extended universe um and
they are working with the rice estate
who i think is being
with her and with her son um
and uh roland jones who recently wrote
the perry mason um
series on hbo is is writing
the is the main writer um and i
when i heard they were doing it
i mean
i have a personal relationship with the
book i just moved to new york i read an
interview with a vampire and i just
loved it and it gave me this feeling
which i think is the main thing i took
away from the book which is you know
every other story you've heard about
empires is kind of [ __ ] and here's
the truth um this is this is the reality
this is what it would really be like uh
and so
i'm involved i'm going to be doing just
the the first couple uh
and we're shooting in new orleans and um
we have a great lust hat and the great
lewis
and you know try and bring some of the
stuff i love about the novel into the
show
um
yeah
so you're so you're doing the first few
episodes um yeah i mean right now i'm
doing the first i'm doing
what would be the pilot the first two um
and executive producing the the
season um and we'll see how it goes
two follow-ups on that if you don't mind
uh when do you actually start shooting
and is the first season like what eight
or ten episodes
uh
right now i think it's yeah at seven or
eight it's gonna be seven or eight um
the first season um and we start
shooting in december
in new orleans um sam reid uh an
australian actor is playing lestat and
uh jacob anderson who was um
in game of thrones is playing louis
uh
very excited last thing for you when i
spoke to akiva a while ago he mentioned
your name with ringworld which i don't
know if you were happy he mentioned or
were sad but i was very surprised when
he said it because you know it's great
to hear news
are you still attached to that are you
doing it what's the status i i uh when i
heard that uh mgm was was working on it
i just pounced on them and said come on
come on come on um because again it was
something i think i read when i was 14
or something and just thought it was the
coolest thing in the world and there are
still ideas in it that i think are the
coolest ideas i've ever come across in
science fiction um the idea of a
character like teela brown um
who's you know basically seventh
generation
lucky
uh
is is so fun to play with so i i was so
excited about it that and the kazinti
and the um
the extended world the puppeteers i just
there's so much i love
so
we were developing it for a while with
various writers and akiva came in and
they were developing it with him and
it was going on for a long time and uh
it's been sort of quiet
with me for a while i went off to do
many saints and um i'm not exactly sure
where they are with it but akiva did
some great
work on it um it's a really challenging
adaptation because
you know what i mostly love is these
brilliant ideas that that
niven has but it's tough to put it in
terms of character and story arc that
play for tv um
and so i think it's it's been a a hard
problem to solve but um
you know i would love to see it done and
would love to participate if it ever
moves ahead
yeah it's um
it's sort of like foundation coming out
now you know took forever yeah you know
yeah i saw the trailer foundation i
thought okay i can feel your pain
i can imagine uh these these series that
people love and that are huge it makes
you realize you know that one of the
gold mines in game of thrones was uh
most of you know a lot of the hard work
of character and story was done it was
already fabricated and some of these
things you have to go in and say okay we
love this about it but
now let's let's build a character in the
story
yeah between you and i um uh i've seen
all of foundation season one and uh
david goyer did a really good job it's a
it's really well done but it's different
than the books you know and i i think
i've i've seen online anyway i've taken
up more of your time than i i was you
know so um i'm just gonna take it to get
off the phone so i guess i guess we're
still okay um but thanks that was a
wide-ranging conversation thank you so
much and um i hope the movie does huge
and you know david uh you know you know
what i mean david gets excited about
another one yeah yeah yeah you know but
cool and congrats on interview with the
vampire that sounds awesome thank you
thank you all right
have a great day
you